[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACOB BANK: All right,
let's get started.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Jacob Bank.
I'm the product lead
for Gmail, and I'm
going to be presenting
along with Ian Leader--
who's here in the front row.
He's the product lead
for Google Calendar,
and we're going to be
talking about time.
We're going to do a little
hero/villain routine.
I'm going to be
the villain that's
going to utterly
depress all of us
by explaining a bunch
of reasons why we're
terrible at managing
our time and how
hopeless the situation is.
And then Ian's going
to be the hero who
comes saves us and tells us
about all the features we're
building in Gmail Calendar
that are trying to take
these behavioral flaws
and mistakes into account
in the way we design products to
help people spend their time as
well as they can.
So we'll start with an
obligatory groan-inducing
cliche--
"Time is precious."
But as we all collectively
roll our eyes,
it's worth spending
a moment to think
about why time is actually
pretty unique as a resource
and why it's particularly
difficult to manage because
of these unique properties.
You can't really save it.
You can't really make
more of it unless you eat,
like, a barrel of
kale every day.
All you can do is spend
it as wisely as possible.
Once it's spent, it's gone.
It's an exercise that I go
through about once a month--
that I'd recommend
all of you go through,
if not now in real time,
maybe after the session ends.
Over lunch, think about the
three most important things you
want to accomplish this year.
Then, look back at your calendar
for the last week, two weeks,
and try to figure out how
much time you actually
spent on those three
most important things.
If you're anything
like me, it will
be a terrifyingly
small amount of time
that you've spent on the
three things that are actually
important to you-- whether
it's in your personal life
or your professional life.
And more generally, you can do
a more general exercise where
you draw a pie chart of
where your time is going now
and a pie chart of where
you'd like your time to go,
and there will probably
be a scary mismatch
between those two.
And it's not just us, it's
actually been studied a bunch.
McKinsey did a study
a few years ago
where they interviewed
a bunch of executives
and asked them how satisfied
they were with the way they
manage their time.
Only 9% said that they were
very satisfied with the way
that they manage their
time, and only 52%
said that the way they
spent their time largely
matched their organization's
strategic priorities.
So while we spend hours
and hours haggling about
do we launch this
feature or that feature?
Or can we save a penny here?
Can we save a nickel there?
We're maybe missing
out on an opportunity
to save half of the time that
we're currently not putting
towards extra
strategic priorities
and line it up better
with our goals.
So, where does that
time actually go?
McKinsey did another
study a couple of years
ago on how a typical knowledge
worker spends their day,
and here are the results.
For the average knowledge
worker, about 28%
of their time reading and
answering email alone.
It's almost three hours in
a typical 40-hour work week.
19% of their time searching
and gathering information,
14% collaborating
internally-- meetings--
and 39% on role-specific
tasks, a.k.a.
the real work that these
people were all hired to do.
Only 39% of their time
spent on real work.
So what we're going
to do in this talk,
my portion of the talk--
I'm going to go through
a bunch of mistakes
that people make in
dealing with their email
and dealing with
their schedules,
and cite some research
from behavioral psychology
and behavioral economics
that helps to explain why
our brains are wired to be bad
at using these tools to make
decisions about how
we spend our time.
I'll start with email.
The first and probably
most debilitating
flaw we face in
dealing with our email
is that it's a constant
source of interruption.
A typical knowledge worker
gets about 120 emails a day,
but what does that cost
in terms of interruption?
Like, maybe I just
check my phone quickly,
put it back in my
pocket, no harm done.
Turns out, there's actually
been a research group
that spent years
studying specifically
email interruptions
in the workplace
and what the cost of
those interruptions is.
And what they found is that when
you actually open your email
client from doing a creative
task like writing a paper
or preparing a presentation,
the average cost
of that interruption
is 25 minutes.
It's a pretty striking number,
and it's going to sound crazy.
But if you actually
think through some
of these scenarios, it'll
probably start to resonate.
So, you get a notification
on your phone,
you're like, oh
crap, that's my boss.
I got to reply to that.
You open up your
email client, you
realize that they're
asking for some number
that you don't have off
the top of your head.
You go to some dashboard,
you find the number,
you compose a
well-crafted email,
you fire it off to your boss.
By that time, another
email has come
in that you need to reply to--
repeat the same routine again.
Then, someone sent you, like,
a video of a dog skateboarding
on a Christmas tree.
You've got to go watch that,
and then in a moment of panic,
you realize that you
actually need to go back
to writing your paper,
preparing your presentation,
wherever the important creative
task is that you were doing.
By that point, you've forgotten
what slide you were working on
or what paragraph
you were writing
and what your train
of thought was,
and you have to re-establish
all of that mental state
before you can continue
to be creative.
And you get a number that's
kind of, like, 25 minutes.
So these interruptions are
extremely costly because we
get distracted very easily.
Second flaw, procrastination.
This is one we've all
heard, experienced.
It's talked about a lot.
Usually, people's mental
model of procrastination
is like a college student--
stays up all night
eating pizza and
playing video games
instead of working
on their term paper,
but there are actually
much more subtle
and devious forms of
procrastination that plague us
throughout the workday.
And that's typically when
we do easy things that
make us feel productive
and give us a quick win
but aren't actually contributing
to our long term productivity
or strategic goals.
And a lot of this
happens in email.
It's a lot easier and
feels a lot more productive
to read a mailing list,
reply to an email,
or chime in on a thread
that totally doesn't need
our opinion, rather than doing
the hard work of producing
a document, or a presentation,
or the kind of creative work
that taxes our
creative capacity.
We just can't
resist an easy win.
And as a result, we don't
spend nearly enough time
on the hard but important stuff.
Third, anyone heard of
Eisenhower's matrix?
The Eisenhower matrix?
It's like, you make
a two-by-two grid,
and you put urgency on
one axis and importance
on the other axis.
And clearly, stuff that is
both urgent and important,
you should do all
of that stuff first.
Clearly, stuff that's
neither important or urgent,
you should never do.
And then the buckets where
people make a lot of mistakes
are, they do things
that are urgent but not
important over things that
are important but not urgent.
And in the case of email,
similar to the procrastination
example, a lot of emails-- we've
probably all seen emails that
have a subject, like, urgent--
please read.
Urgent-- action required.
Depends how we define
urgency, but how many of those
are actually urgent?
Like, if you don't
reply this second,
the world is going to explode.
Probably not many of them.
And so that same research
group that I mentioned
that's done a lot of work
on email interruption
has also studied email
batching behavior,
and it turns out that if you do
fewer sessions in email a day--
like, three long
sessions where you
deal with all of your email
instead of 50 short sessions
where you deal with only
one email at a time--
you're both more productive
and less stressed.
But again, it's very
hard for us to resist
that, urgent-- please read.
Urgent-- please reply, even
when it's not actually urgent,
and we should be doing our
important work instead.
Fourth, our inability to say no.
How many of us have
ever received an email
where someone else is
asking us to do something?
Probably all of us.
Probably, you all have like
10 in your inbox right now.
Saying no is really hard because
social conventions dictate
that we need to come up with a
really, really good excuse that
makes us and the
requester feel comfortable
about the rejection
of their request.
And the cognitive load
of making these excuses
is so high that we
often think, oh, I
might as well just do the thing
rather than making the excuse.
But rarely is that
actually the smart choice
in terms of time management
and prioritization.
And because of this
social convention
that makes it very
hard for us to say no,
the result is that people
set our priorities for us.
Like, a lot of people
have said things like,
an email is like a to-do list
that other people write to.
And it's true, largely, because
of the social convention
that we feel obligated to
not only act, but act quickly
on what people ask us to do.
OK, we're halfway through--
halfway through.
Number five, Parkinson's law.
It's not actually a law,
but it's the principle
that I think we've
all experienced--
that work expands to fill
the time allotted to it.
And this is particularly
true of meetings.
So, most calendaring systems
default the meeting length
to one hour.
How many of you have ever
been in a meeting scheduled
for an hour that
really only needed
to happen for 20 minutes?
But everyone, you
know, stretches
out the time for the full
hour anyway because you
got the room booked, you got
all the people in the room,
might as well use it.
But it turns out, this is
actually a huge waste of time--
if you add up, cumulatively,
all these hour-long meetings
that really should have
been half-hour meetings.
And it's very hard to have the
discipline to stop a meeting
when it's done and not when
the next person kicks you out
of the meeting room.
Number six, the
planning fallacy.
This is an effect that was first
discovered or first written
about in 1979 by
Tversky and Kahneman--
the famous behavioral
economists--
and it refers to our systematic
underestimation of how long
things take.
Turns out, we apply
an optimism bias
whenever we're
projecting how long it's
going to take for a
project to complete
or for us to do even a
simple individual task.
And the reason for
that is when we're
making a projection on how long
a project is going to take,
we have this optimistic
lens that everything
is going to go smoothly
the entire time,
even though no project in
the history of humanity
has ever gone smoothly
the entire time.
It's just a different thing that
goes wrong each time, so it's
very hard to reason about.
And how off we are depends a
lot based on the circumstance,
and there's a
bunch of tricks you
can use to try to be more
accurate at estimating.
But a good rule of
thumb is that projects
will take about double
what we think they will.
It's a good rule of
thumb that's been proven
across a variety of cases,
and the really particularly
depressing thing about
the planning fallacy
is that even if you tell
someone right before
they're about to make an
estimation of how long
something is going to take--
that we are subject to
this behavioral flaw--
they're still going
to underestimate
how long it's going to take.
Because again, they're
not going to see
all of the little things
that will go wrong
that are abstracted
away when you
have an optimistic and
rosy picture of what's
going to happen.
Related to the underestimation
of how long things will take
is the overestimation
of how available
we'll be in the future.
So if I ask any one of you,
can you spend four hours
with me this afternoon meeting?
You'll say, no
way, that's crazy.
I'm at a conference.
I'm super busy.
I've got a bunch
of meetings to do,
I can't possibly spend
four hours with you.
If I ask you, can you
spend four hours with me
over the week of July 20?
You'll look at your
calender and say, yeah, sure
I've got four weeks on
the week of July 20.
Now in reality, you're
going to be just as
busy the week of July
20 as you are now.
You just don't know what the
things are yet that you're
going to be busy with.
And the further we are in
the future, the less and less
concrete the other obligations
that are vying for our time
are, so the more
we underestimate
how busy we'll be.
And that's how you
end up doing things,
like, two years
from now, you commit
to a two-week-long workshop.
And then by the
time you get there,
you can't imagine
how you ever would
have committed to that
because you clearly don't
have enough time to do it.
Last one, productive time.
So, our cognitive capacity
varies throughout the day,
and if you're like
most people, you're
at your most productive in the
morning between roughly 8:00 AM
and 11:00 AM.
Usually, like, after you've
had your first cup of coffee
before you get super
hungry for lunch.
And if you're like most
people-- if you're like me--
that's when you're, kind
of, rolling into the office,
you're checking email,
catching up on the news,
easing your way into the day.
And then after lunch--
when we're all at our
least productive, typically
the post-lunch dip,
1:00 to 2:00 PM--
you realize you actually need
to get your real work done
and try to buckle
down, but simply don't
have the energy to do so.
And that's because we do a
very poor job of recognizing
how our cognitive capacity
changes throughout the day,
and how to align the cognitive
capacity of our mental state
with the cognitive capacity
required by the tasks
that we need to do.
So we misuse our
most precious hours
pretty much every morning.
So we add all of this
up, we get interrupted,
we procrastinate, we do
things that are urgent but not
important, we can't say no,
we waste a bunch of time
in meetings that should've
ended more quickly,
we underestimate how long
everything is going to take,
we overestimate how
much time we have,
we misuse our most
precious hours a day--
it's not a shock that people
think that 50% of their time
is not going to their
strategic priorities.
And it's a bleak outlook--
it's kind of a downer.
It feels a little bit hopeless.
But now I'll turn
it over to Ian,
and Ian's going to tell us
about a bunch of the features
that we're building in Google
Calendar and into Gmail
to take into account all of
these behavioral principles
that make us naturally
bad at managing time.
And hopefully, we
can make it better.
IAN LEADER: Thank you, Jacob.
OK, so let's talk solutions.
The problems that Jacob
described probably
aren't new to a lot of you.
There's hundreds of books,
online articles, training
courses about how to manage
your time, but most of us
are still doing a poor job.
So clearly, reading a book on
productivity is not enough.
So, how do we solve this?
The renowned behavioral
economist Dan Ariely
often says that, like, one
of the biggest lessons we've
had from behavioral economics
is that decisions we make
are shaped by the
environment that we're in.
A great example of this--
from outside the workplace--
is contribution to retirement
plans like 401(k)s.
There's a large body
of research that
shows that most people
will only save enough
during their working
life if, by default,
contributions to the plan
out of their pay packet
happen automatically.
So, we think that the best
way to help people improve
their time management
behavior is
to change the environment
they're operating in,
and that raises the
question at work,
which environment
should we change
to get the biggest benefit?
And we think Gmail
and Calendar are key,
and that's not just
because we work on them.
To repeat the
figures from McKinsey
that Jacob mentioned earlier,
the average knowledge worker
is spending almost three hours
a day in which environment?
In their email client
and their calendar.
So around 90% of the
large companies that
use G Suite today,
employee calendars
are shared with the
entire organization.
That means, anyone can look
and see when you're available
and schedule a meeting with you.
This is a really powerful
tool for collaboration,
but it can have the
unfortunate side effect
that people start to
manage your time for you.
And as Jacob said, once
that meeting invite arrives,
we're not actually
very good at saying no.
So first of all, I'm going
to look at some of the tools
that we already have in
Gmail and Calendar that
will help you,
and then I'm going
to talk about the future of
things we haven't released yet
that we're thinking about
as new ways to do this.
OK, so Priority Inbox.
It's been around for a while,
many of you may have seen this.
It was one of the early
intelligence features
that we put into
Gmail back in 2010.
And so, Priority Inbox
uses a variety of signals
to work out which emails
are likely important to you,
and it shows these
at the top separately
from all the other emails.
So, what kind of signals?
For example, we look at
who you email to the most
because emails coming
to you from those people
are likely important to you.
And we also look
at which emails you
read, which emails you open,
which emails you reply to,
and we consider emails
similar to those
more important than
the kind of emails
that you typically skip over.
And so what all of that
means is when you open Gmail,
you're looking at
the important stuff
with fewer distractions that
can lead to procrastination.
And there's also
fewer interruptions
because you can set
your phone to buzz only
when it's one of
these priority emails
that are arriving--
not the rest.
And we have another tool
in the product today
that's also around
elevating important emails,
and that's Tabbed Inbox.
And it's ideal if
you want more control
than Priority Inbox
gives you about how
your email is divided up.
Particularly, if you
subscribe to a lot of forums,
or if you get a lot of
updates from systems
like workflow systems or
project management systems.
And Tabbed Inbox automatically
categorizes the email,
so there's forums
like Google Groups.
There's updates, like,
an invoice coming in
for your approval.
And then there's the Primary
Inbox, which is usually
stuff from real people.
And like Priority Inbox,
this reduces distractions
and makes it easier to batch
up those email sessions
into fewer, larger sessions.
It's changing time slightly.
One of the reasons people allow
themselves to get distracted
by non-urgent emails is
because they keep them
around in their
inbox because they're
scared that if they don't,
then they'll forget about them.
And they'll drop the ball,
and they won't follow up.
So, we introduced
the snooze feature,
which will let you hide an
email until a future time--
or until you're in
a future location.
And that gets it out of the
way, but doesn't give you
the cognitive load of having
to remember to get back to it.
Instead, we'll bump it
to the top of your inbox
when that time or place
arrives, so you can't miss it.
And snoozing is available
in the inbox client,
which alongside
Gmail, works well
for a variety of
different workflows,
including the zero
inbox approach.
So let's take a look
at Calendar, now.
Jacob talked about
the one-hour meetings
that really need to be one
hour, so what if you just
had shorter meetings?
Well, when you start using
Google Calendar in G Suite
today, the default length
for meetings is one hour.
Maybe we should change
that, but you can set it
to anything you like.
You can set it 10
minutes, 15 minutes,
30 minutes what have you.
Now, I'm not saying that you
should make every meeting 10
minutes long, although,
it would be nice
if that was actually possible.
But by using the
power of defaults,
you can change the environment
so that your default of, say,
15 minutes makes it
less work to schedule
a short meeting than it does
to schedule a long meeting.
So that's a pretty simple hack
to help reduce your meeting
load, but we've also been
working on some more, sort of,
complex problems and solutions.
In particular, how can we help
people spend more time focusing
on long-term productive tasks
despite this tendency to become
distracted and procrastinate?
So, let me quickly
talk about a study that
was published in the "British
Journal of Health Psychology"
a few years ago.
And it was about,
how do you get people
to exercise more frequently?
So, there were three groups
of participants in this study,
in the first group--
in the control group, which is
people in their natural state,
just let them do
what they want--
around 38% of the
participants did
exercise at least once a week.
And so the question
is, how can we
get more people to do exercise?
So, the first thing they did
is they took the second group--
they called the
motivation group--
and they tried to motivate them.
They gave them a brochure on
why exercise is good for you.
They talked to them about
coronary heart disease
and how terribly
unpleasant this is,
and how exercise can
actually help overcome this.
And so you'd think that you
would get a positive outcome
from this, but guess what?
You didn't.
In fact, there was a
slight drop in the number
of participants in that group
exercising at least once
a week.
However, there was
a third group--
the intention group--
and in this group,
the participants were asked
to commit a day and a time
when you will do you
exercise next week,
and the week after, and so on.
And here, the
impact was massive.
There we go.
We actually saw that--
in that study they saw
that 91% of participants
were exercising at
least once a week,
and that's a 160%
increase over the control.
So, when we think about
this in a work context,
what does it tell us?
Like, being motivated is
not, on its own, enough.
You're motivated, right?
You all want to do
a great job at work.
You all want to have an impact.
None of you want to get fired.
But that, on its own, is
not enough to overcome
these cognitive failures
that get in the way of how
we spend our time well.
However, scheduling
can make a difference.
The problem is,
scheduling everything
that you're going to
do into your calendar
is actually hard work.
And so many people, even
when they know about this,
they don't do that extra
work of scheduling.
So what we decided to
do was build a feature
into the Google Calendar
product called Goals.
And this is about
taking the work out
of scheduling time for
these long-term goals.
And we launched it
almost a year ago.
Basically, you tell Calendar
what you want to do,
how long you want to do
it for, and how often
you want to do it.
And Calendar takes
care of setting up
the sessions by
automatically blocking out
time on your calendar.
So, how do we find
good times for you
to do this if all you're telling
us is how frequently you want
to exercise, or how frequently
you want to spend focused time?
So, we start by picking
times that, in general, make
sense for everyone.
For example, if it's around
focused productive time
in the morning.
We obviously look at what's
in your Calendar already,
because we wouldn't
be helping you
if we schedule time over
an existing meeting.
And then, the system
learns over time.
So for example, if we
scheduled every Tuesday
at 6:00 PM for
you to go running,
and you always check that as
done, we know it works for you,
and we'll keep
scheduling it then.
But on the other hand,
if we put productive time
for coding into your calendar
every Wednesday morning,
and you keep moving it
to Tuesday and Thursday,
then we'll learn that
Wednesday isn't good
and start scheduling
it on the other days.
Now, we designed Goals to
work with a broad range
of different types.
Exercise is very, very
popular, but we also
see quite a lot of people
using it for work-centric goals
like having a daily block
for planning in the calendar
or focused time like the coding
example you can see here.
So, this sort of
takes the effort out
of doing the scheduling, so you
don't have to do it manually.
Does it still have
the desired effect
of getting you to commit more?
And it turns out
that, yes, it does--
I'm pleased to say.
So last summer
after we launched,
we ran an eight-week
95-participant study
with people using this
feature, and by the end of it,
74% said that it was helping
them to meet their goals.
And perhaps more
importantly, on average,
participants were
spending 30% more time
on their goals at
the end of the study
than they were at the beginning.
And we also saw a big increase
in the actual amount of time
people were spending.
So as you can see
from this chart,
there was a 100% increase in
the number of participants
who were spending four or
more hours a week on what they
described as their
most important goal.
So great, we think it works.
OK so, let's move
on to the future.
I've just taken you through
some of the things that
are in the product today--
you can use it right now--
and I want to take you through
some sorts of explorations.
How we're thinking
about improving
the product in the future.
Now, we're really excited
about these ideas.
We're excited to
tell you about them.
We'd love to get
feedback from you,
but please remember
they're explorations.
They're not committed features.
So, they might not end up
in the product in the form
that you are about to see.
They might not end up
in the product at all.
That caveat aside, let's
have a look at what
we're thinking about for email.
So, Priority Inbox
and Tabbed Inbox
are good at getting
rid of the clutter,
but for very busy
email inboxes, there's
still a lot of emails in there.
And it's hard for people to know
which email to look at first.
So, the Highlights exploration,
which you can see here,
builds on Priority Inbox by more
accurately elevating the most
important and urgent emails.
And it does this by using
NLP to actually look at what
is the content of the email?
And so, for example, it
could elevate an email
where someone has
requested a response today.
Particularly, if that's
also someone that we know
is important to you.
And in addition to
that, it actually
shows a rationale, which you can
see in gray above each email,
explaining why
we've elevated that.
So you can more
easily make a decision
about whether you want to
act on my email now or later.
In working together with this,
we have a second exploration--
the limited notifications
exploration.
And this is about getting
fewer interruptions
by only being notified
when those most
important emails arrive.
And it's not just about looking
at the most important emails,
but it also takes your
context into account.
What are you doing?
So if you're in a
meeting, for example,
or if it's outside your
normal working hours,
then the threshold-- the bar--
of actually buzzing your phone
is going to be higher
than if you're at work
or not doing anything
in particular.
Changing type slightly.
So we talked about
snooze, and how
snooze could help you make sure
that you didn't drop the ball
and forget to reply.
But snooze is kind of manual.
You still have to
actually decide
when you're going to
snooze that email to
and that you want to
snooze that email.
So in this
exploration, again, we
use NLP to automatically detect
which emails are requesting
a response from you, or why
you have requested a response
in an email you've sent.
And if there's been no
response in either direction
for a certain period
of time, we'll
bump those to the
top of your inbox.
Again telling you, hey, you
haven't replied for three days,
or perhaps, you want
to follow this up
because the other
person hasn't replied
for some amount of time.
OK, so let's go
back to Calendar.
So we talked a
lot about the fact
that we're bad at saying no.
So what if Calendar said no
so that you didn't have to?
So in this
exploration, we've been
thinking about, what
if we let users specify
a limit on how
much time they want
to spend on meetings each week?
15 hours in this case.
Essentially, taking that
pie chart of time-use
that Jacob was talking about
and making it an integral part
of the product.
So what could we do?
Well essentially, we could
change the scheduling
environment.
Not for you, but for
all of your colleagues
who try to schedule
time with you.
So if they try and set up a
meeting with you that would
violate your limits,
we can push back--
before that invite
has gone out--
and we can actually
tell them, hey, there's
a cost of scheduling
with you, right?
Because you're busy.
And we can provide a
low-friction way out
by suggesting times.
You can see that here
in the middle screenshot
where you're both available.
Where you've both got time.
Where you're not
violating the limits.
And if they really want to have
that meeting with you anyway
because maybe it is
urgent, we nudge them
into actually justifying
themselves to you
rather than just sending
an anonymous invite
and leaving all
work of saying no
and justifying not going to you.
OK, finally, we thought
about what would Goals
look like if it was
focused on making sure
that you were allocating
enough focused time
to do productive work?
And so we thought about a couple
of things in this exploration.
Obviously, we've talked
a lot about making sure
that time is scheduled
in the morning,
and making sure we get
other things out of the way.
So you can have your
focused time in the morning.
We looked at having a
do-not-disturb mode that
could be even more aggressive
at getting rid of disruptions,
like for example, stopping
Hangout's chat notifications
from happening.
In addition, when we talk to
people who currently block out
time manually on Calendar
for "make time today"
or use the Goals feature,
a common complaint
was that their colleagues
ignore the block.
They say, oh, it's a work block.
I can schedule over that because
they're not in a meeting.
So again, we want to change
the scheduling environment.
So we're calling out
the fact that if you're
going to interrupt someone, that
there's a cost to doing that,
and here are some
times which are more
appropriate for having a meeting
rather than doing focused work.
OK, so that's some
of the ways we're
thinking about changing Gmail
and Calendar in the future.
I hope this has been interesting
and a good use of your time.
In conclusion, we
think that when
it comes to managing your time
better, the environment is key.
So if you only remember
three things from today,
this is what we'd recommend.
First of all, use the Google
Mail and Calendar clients
on your phone and tablet
as well as on the laptop.
It will help you today, and
it's going to help you even more
in the future.
Secondly, unless your role
at work is entirely reactive,
block out a healthy
dose of "make time"
in the calendar in the
mornings so that you
can get productive work done.
And tell your colleagues,
because if you all
respect each
other's "make time,"
you're all going to be more
effective and more productive.
So with that, good luck
with your time management.
Thank you very
much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]